I I know I talked to you when Zombieland
came out and you got an MTV award
nomination which has to be cool right
but it was it was very similar to the
Entertainment Weekly uh uh Herald
because uh it was the the award was was
uh best scared as uh than there was four
asterisks and then performance
so you could fill that in at home
um
and here
um but uh you know again it was
something you know I've been trying to
uh you know avoid my whole life not
being scared and now I'm being lauded
for it you know
so you finally get this cool MTV award
and it's for being really frightened in
a movie yeah exactly they could have
given me that just uh for My Life
uh the MTV award I was only nominated if
it was in my life I would be the winner
and I didn't go to the award show but
you know because of that because well
because I find a word shows frightening
so nothing would confirm that I should
be nominated for that then going to it
and um and then I didn't get the award
because I suspect oh well I don't know
maybe I didn't deserve it maybe I didn't
earn it from Zombieland what did I do
wrong in it um I don't know but uh
what they see you know with some with a
lot of award shows they give the awards
to the people that that go yes yes yeah
yes there are a lot of award shows yeah
yeah do you have a therapist
you know I'm working with a with a small
team now
they're backstage they did my hair
makeup and took my pulse before I came
out
and they said I'm good to go good and
then after the show they ice me yeah
there's a bathtub back there and I stay
there for a few minutes I lower your
body temperature for a while lower the
body temperature and then they drive me
to a hospital
I think I wouldn't need because the body
temperature is already lowered
I'm so scared for you
[Applause]
sincerely you've had this level of
success uh that is astounding and as I
said well deserved but you do not seem
to have changed you just seem like the
same Jesse that I met a number of years
ago very self-effacing nice person has
your life changed considerably since you
know social network came out I've gotten
more cats uh
man when I when I'm Millions
crazy old lady and I make it
schizophrenia
um uh and my apartment I think will
smell no you know I I I'm a foster you
know parent for for cats um um and uh
the more movies I do the more guilty I
feel and um the more cats I feel the
need to get to you know alleviate the
guilt from doing the movies and then if
a movie is God forbid popular then I
have to get even more cats
um cats do you have now well I know I'm
gonna say it and it's gonna sound like I
have two now but I you know I'm on kind
of a list where they can deliver them to
the house so it's two at the moment I
mean any like a pizza anytime Hollywood
yeah man and this is uh this is here or
in New York City in New York where I
live and um if you haven't been to New
York the apartments are tiny I mean I
know of course you've been to New York
but um yes and so to have to be a foster
parent for cats is basically to have
like you know tenants coming in and out
like if you live in a house it'd be like
the equivalent of having like a lot of
people coming and staying over yeah uh
because uh my apartment so small and um
so I have a lot of cats a lot of cat
food a lot of litter and um and nothing
else in the apartment
yeah so just cat paraphernalia is what
you have my life is basically just you
know feeding and cleaning cats
and then I get to be the sexiest geek
alive
[Applause]